i
[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski dice haber visto señales
positivas tras la reunión de este martes
entidad representantes de moscú y kiev
en estambul russian se compromete a
reducir su actividad en torno a kiev la
capital y de chernin hiv mientras que la
delegación ucraniana afirmó tiene la
voluntad para declararse como un estado
neutral tenemos el reporte desde
estambul
occidente recibe los resultados de las
negociaciones con cautela eeuu francia
alemania reino unido e italia abogan por
no bajar la guardia no veremos si
cumplen afirmó el presidente yo vice de
mientras que el pentágono advierte que
cree que no hay una retirada de las
tropas rusas así no un reposicionamiento
en israel cinco personas murieron por un
tiroteo en un suburbio ultraortodoxo de
la vid mientras que el atacante falleció
por los disparos de las fuerzas de
seguridad es el tercer ataque con
pistola o arma blanca en la última
semana en el país tenemos informe desde
jerusalén
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en france 24 gracias por
mantenerse en nuestra señal mi nombre es
oficiales comenzamos con el conflicto
entre rusia y ucrania el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski dice haber
visto señales positivas tras el
encuentro de cerca de cuatro horas que
delegaciones de kiev y moscú celebraron
en estambul turquía rusia se comprometió
a reducir radicalmente su actividad
alrededor de kiev la capital y de
chernin hiv una ciudad al norte del país
por su parte la representación ucraniana
afirmó tener la voluntad de declarar
declararse como un estado neutral algo
que frenaría sus aspiraciones para
unirse a la otan que es uno de los
reclamos de rusia escuchemos las
palabras del presidente es el esquí
más debate
si podemos decir que las señales que
escuchamos de las conversaciones son
positivas pero estas señales no pueden
silenciar las explosiones de los
proyectiles rusos maxim o estéis aquí
por supuesto estamos viendo todos los
riesgos por supuesto no vemos motivos
para confiar en las palabras que vienen
de los representantes del país que sigue
para destruirnos de nación es la de hoy
fue una ronda de conversaciones en donde
las dos partes alcanzaron el progreso
más significativo según el gobierno de
turquía quien hace de anfitrión y
mediador entre rusia y kiev entre rusia
y ucrania incluso se está hablando de un
eventual encuentro entre los presidentes
vladimir putin y por los emires selenski
con los detalles de esta jornada de
conversaciones estaban desde estambul
nuestro corresponsal adrián rocha quien
nos envió el siguiente reporte
tras algo más de cuatro horas reunidos
en estambul las delegaciones su crean en
rusa para los procesos de paz después de
haber empezado este proceso en
bielorrusia pasarlo online y ahora
empezaron a estambul han hablado de
estas charlas como un proceso
constructivo y positivo que puede seguir
en el futuro y han establecido los
puntos básicos para continuar con estas
negociaciones lo ha hecho sobre todo el
jefe de la delegación ucraniana que ha
explicado los dos grandes puntos bases a
partir de los cuales ucrania quiere
continuar con estas negociaciones el
primero de ellos es la neutralidad de
ucrania en respecto que lo que respecta
a la otan un kn se compromete a no pedir
la entrada a este a esta unión traer
sanz lácticas y recibe el compromiso de
varios países extranjeros de proteger y
defender a ucrania en caso de una nueva
ofensiva militar y una nueva ocupación
ocupación en contra de su propio
territorio estos países podrían ser
varios incluyendo los eeuu gran bretaña
francia
alemania y turquía además también este
jefe de relación delegación ucraniana ha
establecido un periodo de 15 años
futuros en los que ucrania pediría
estudiar con rusia el futuro de la
península de crimea ocupada por rusia
desde 2014 y ucrania se compromete
durante en estos 15 años no atacar y no
llevar a cabo ninguna operación militar
en contra de este territorio además por
su parte el jefe de la declaración rusa
ha sido mucho más escueto en lo que
respecta a lo que ha comentado sobre
esta reunión ha dicho que ha sido muy
constructiva como ya hemos ya venimos
comentando pero sobre todo ha dicho que
para facilitar que estas negociaciones
puedan continuar y rusia se compromete a
frenar y a parar sobre todo frenando sus
ofensivas en la capital ucraniana kiev y
la ciudad de herning y turquía a quien
está facilitando estas conversaciones de
espera que puedan continuar en un futuro
y van a hacerlo mañana no van a hacerlo
pero sí que en las próximas semanas
esperan que ucrania rusa puedan reunirse
otra vez y continuar con estas
negociaciones que de momento parece que
pueden ir a buen puerto
las potencias occidentales reaccionaron
con cautela las conclusiones de hoy en
las negociaciones entre rusia y ucrania
eeuu francia alemania reino unido e
italia abogan por que moscú siga pagando
el precio de su intervención militar los
líderes de estas naciones mantuvieron
este martes una conversación telefónica
aseguraron que no puede haber una
distensión en su determinación contra el
horror que vive el pueblo ucraniano por
su parte el pentágono advirtió que cree
que los recientes movimientos de las
tropas rusas pueden no ser una retirada
sino un reposicionamiento el presidente
job aiden dijo que hay que esperar
no interpretó nada hasta ver cuáles son
sus acciones veremos si siguen adelante
con lo que están sugiriendo hay
negociaciones que han comenzado hoy
bueno no comenzado continuaron hoy una
en turquía y otras tuvieron la reunión
con los jefes de estado de nuestros
cuatro aliados en la otan francia
alemania eeuu y gran bretaña parece
haber un consenso de que vamos a ver qué
tienen para ofrecer ya veremos que hacen
pero mientras tanto vamos a seguir
manteniendo fuertes sanciones
continuaremos brindando al ejército
ucraniano capacidad para defenderse
vamos a seguir vigilando de cerca lo que
está pasando
en medio de estos esfuerzos diplomáticos
del presidente de francia en manuel
macro sostuvo una conversación
telefónica con su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin de acuerdo con el elíseo moscú
tiene una postura difícil de cara a
permitir el ingreso de la ayuda
humanitaria de la ciudad de mariupol
quería un fuerte asedio y en donde miles
de civiles pueden a ver muertos según
naciones unidas el gobierno francés
expresó que no hay condiciones para una
misión humanitaria en esta urbe además
el presidente macrón le hizo saber a
putin que se opone a pagar las
importaciones de gas ruso en rublos como
pretende moscú
continuamos hablando de mario x porque
todavía no hay claridad sobre el alcance
de los daños allí unas 100.000 personas
siguen viviendo en la ciudad enormemente
destruida en medio de la del asedio de
las fuerzas rusas nuestros colegas de
fans realizaron este reporte desde el
interior de la urbe devastada
la pulverizada marido paul parece un
pueblo fantasma pudimos entrar en una
parte de la ciudad donde fuimos
escoltados por fuerzas rusas y
separatistas ahora tienen el control
aquí ninguna casa o edificio parece
haberse librado del fuego cruzado en las
calles vacías algunos residentes
deambulan desorientados como este hombre
con la cara cubierta de hollín
a dónde vas vuelvo a mi casa
pero allí no queda ninguna casa
todavía queda algo es el vecino
parece que ya no oye los bombardeos en
la distancia
la electricidad la calefacción y el agua
están cortadas desde hace casi un mes
los que quedan como oksana viven
hacinados en el subsuelo
ahora somos 50 personas los bombardeos
dan mucho miedo las condiciones de vida
son nefastas hay polvo por todas partes
las mujeres y los niños duermen en estos
colchones habían días en los que no
teníamos nada que comer dábamos a los
niños galletas o lo que tuviéramos ahora
el frente se ha movido podemos salir
pero solo para cocinar
un poco más lejos de donde se refugia
oksana esto es lo que queda del teatro
de mariupol fue aquí en el sótano donde
se refugiaron varios cientos de civiles
estas imágenes fueron tomadas por un
canal de televisión ruso no muestra
ningún cuerpo dentro de lo que queda del
edificio donde se teme que murieron 300
personas en un solo ataque ruso cerca de
una de las salidas de la ciudad los
residentes huyen de la devastación los
soldados separatistas registran a todos
los que salen los hombres deben quitarse
las camisas esto es para demostrar que
no están luchando por ucrania es para
que los ss no huyan todo lo de los
batallones ultranacionalistas tienen
tatuajes de las ss familias enteras se
van muchas de ellas con lo poco que aún
tiene nietos estoy muy cansado y mis
juguetes no tienen batería las ventanas
de nuestra casa explotaron el proyecto
niña
y en casa de los abuelos y de mi amigo
el apartamento se quemó todo se quemó
[Música]
la casa de esta mujer también se quemó
nos cuenta que se lleva todo lo que le
queda en el plano económico los
llamantes han ruso siguen escapando las
sanciones europeas los que saben de
piedras preciosas los llaman los
diamantes las lágrimas de la tundra que
representan más de un tercio de la
oferta mundial algunos piden un embargo
europeo a este sector sobre todo porque
el gigante ruso del diamante al rosa es
muy cercano al kremlin más en el
siguiente informe por estas calles
aparentemente banales pasan cada año
miles de millones de euros en piedras
preciosas
estamos en el barrio de los diamantes de
amberes donde la gente intenta pasar
desapercibida desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania rounds nine alrededor
del 95% de los diamantes en bruto que
entran en la unión europea llegan aquí a
esta calle y aproximadamente un tercio
son de origen ruso
y importaciones que aún no están sujetas
a las sanciones europeas
este investigador trabaja para una ong
del proceso de kimberley que lucha
contra los diamantes que financian la
guerra y las violaciones de derechos
humanos desde la invasión de ucrania se
han alzado algunas voces para investigar
la red de diamantes rusos en el punto de
mira al rosa un grupo minero que
pertenece en más de un 30% al kremlin
grandes grupos en las últimas semanas ha
habido informes que han sacado a la luz
vínculos más directos de 'la rosa' que
es una empresa que contribuye
directamente al aparato militar y
nuclear ruso y estos son elementos que
deben ser examinados con más detalle de
momento la unión europea ha sancionado
la exportación de diamantes tallados a
rusia esto es suficiente para esta
activista que pide más severidad en
particular para remediar los defectos
del proceso de kimberley
hay límites a nivel del proceso de
kimberley sessions en particular en lo
que respecta a su definición que sólo se
refiere a los grupos rebeldes en el caso
de rusia no se trata de grupos rebeldes
que financiarían al conflicto a través
del comercio de diamantes sino de
fuerzas gubernamentales
pero para este profesor de economía
antes cercano a la industria del
diamante las sanciones castigarían sobre
todo al sector europeo que ya se
enfrenta a una fuerte competencia de
otros países efectos fuentes disensiones
y sólo sería eficaz si estas sanciones
fueran adoptadas por todos pero sabemos
que india dubai o incluso israel no
adoptan las mismas sanciones el
resultado sólo sería que europa perdería
una importante industria luces láser
importa entiendo street with cels por su
parte eeuu ha impuesto sanciones a las
importaciones de diamantes en bruto
procedentes de rusia pero es difícil
imaginar un boicot total ya que una vez
talladas es imposible conocer el origen
de ciertas piedras
como anticipábamos en titulares cinco
personas perdieron la vida en medio de
un tiroteo en un suburbio ultraortodoxo
de la ciudad de tel aviv en israel la
policía mató al atacante quien sería de
origen árabe israelí es de jerusalén
nuestra corresponsal yanira gómez muñoz
tiene los detalles de un nuevo episodio
de violencia en el país
tercer atentado terrorista en israel en
tan solo una semana tras los ataques con
cuchillo y arma de fuego en ver chivas y
jáder a la periferia de tel aviv ha sido
el escenario de un nuevo tiroteo con
cinco víctimas mortales en esta ocasión
un motorista armado de un fusil m-16 fue
quien disparó a transeúntes y vecinos de
las ciudades de vela y brack y ramat gan
dicho atacante que también murió en la
escena fue identificado como un joven
palestino de cisjordania algo que éste
distingue de los otros autores árabes
israelíes simpatizantes del estado
islámico con un total de 11 personas
muertas en siete días los más
sangrientos desde el año 2006 el primer
ministro naftalí bennett declaró que
israel se enfrenta a una ola mortal de
terrorismo árabe contra la cual prometió
luchar con mano de hierro un mensaje que
está lejos de calmar las tensiones en
vísperas de abril mes que ya inquietaba
por la coincidencia del ramadán la
semana santa cristiana y la pascua judía
muestra del temor a una nueva espiral de
violencia son las reacciones a este
atentado por ejemplo celebrado por hamas
y la jihad islámica a la vez que
repudiado por los ultraortodoxos de pena
y vrac al grito de muerte a los árabes
en medio en un gesto poco común el
presidente palestino mahmud abás condenó
la matanza diciendo que conduce a un
deterioro de la situación ante este
escenario la policía israelí ya ha
decretado el nivel de alerta máximo que
es a su más recientes redadas en barrios
árabes y ensayos de alarmas antiaéreas
por su parte benet liderará este
miércoles un gabinete de seguridad en el
que revisará el actual plan de
contención
y por segundo día consecutivo cientos de
personas salieron a las calles de nueva
delhi para protestar contra las
políticas económicas impuestas por el
primer ministro narendra modi los
manifestantes de unos 12 sindicatos
corearon consignas antigubernamentales
mientras exigían una cobertura universal
de seguridad social un aumento del
salario mínimo que se elimine una ley
que permita a los empresarios fijar los
sueldos y las horas de trabajo y además
que se evite la privatización de algunos
bancos públicos el gobierno de moody
asegura que la privatización de estos
bancos ayudaría a recaudar dinero para
estimular la economía
hasta aquí esta emisión informativa en
frases 24 pero quédense en nuestra
pantalla y visiten también nuestra
página web france24 puntocom
[Música]